I'm about aiming at something right like
it doesn't have to be the perfect goal
but aim at something and along that
Journey you're going to discover a lot
of things about yourself but also what
you don't like and what you do like and
we know that the human being is most
happy when they're making progress even
if it's miniature little progress goals
like Alex was talking about we get a
little dopamine hit we get some
validation that we're on the right path
towards what we're aiming at right aim
at something that fulfills you that gets
you excited that makes you curious and
from there start taking small steps in
action with a lot of athletes that I
work with they ask me well what should I
do what's the adventure I should take on
what do you think I should do next
and it's more diving into what they're
curious about or what invigorates them
or wonder what they've always wondered I
wonder if I can do that and if there's a
string to pull there that's the
direction to start heading in